let's get into holiday mode which makes
us wonder who doesn't love an edible
arrangement rocky stop by a local shop
for some fresh fruit and ideas for
holiday gifting this year
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi welcome to edible arrangement my name
is basil daniel and this is the south
rainbow location
uh as we know the holidays are
approaching fast and we are known to
help our communities celebrate with
their loved ones with the best gifts
ideas that we have for them so we do
have eight stores in las vegas and we
deliver all over the valley and you can
come to the stores and get any items you
want or you can go to edible.com and
place your orders there and you can pick
them up at the store or have them
delivered in our refrigerated vans one
of my favorite gifts to give and receive
is an edible arrangement so i'm so
excited to talk about your bee sweet
campaign for the holidays what do you
have for us this is the christmas
selection we have we have the christmas
platter we have the jolly village
different sizes for all the budgets we
have the the double decker box we have
our regular boxes and we have the
curated box that has cheese jelly nuts
uh the new
peppermint popcorn and our penguin for
christmas that is so good and when
people are coming in obviously you can
order online pre-order but people can
also walk in and grab on the go right
yeah we have the grab-and-go items so we
have a lot of stuff we have our bake
shop that we have cupcakes cheesecakes
cookies and we do have smoothies as well
that we make i saw that i already
ordered one yeah and then
banana we do have flowers that they can
make and if something we don't have our
shelf we can make something in 10
minutes or 15 depending on the size and
how much dipping is involved in it
perfect well happy holidays happy hour
to you guys
thank you to edible arrangements for
sponsoring this segment we have eight
las vegas and henderson edible locations
for more information just head to
edible.com and remember they offer free
next day delivery